les cinémas de quartiers font leur
révolution les grands complexes les
ondes peut-être un peu poussé à se
moderniser nous allons en tout cas poser
la question à deux nouveaux invités Luc
bocambon soi le sol le directeur du ciné
cet high en cours également bonsoir à
vous vous êtes responsable du grenier à
sel c'est à Trappes vos deux
établissements se modernisent alors là
on n'a pas tout à fait encore ouvert les
travaux sont en cours ça a pris un petit
peu de retard vous allez nous expliquer
mais en tout cas du côté du grenier à
sel ça y est c'est officiel les
projections peuvent se faire maintenant
en 4K 4K c'est la très haute définition
on peut dire ça oui alors comment ça
fonctionne qu'est-ce qui est si
différent à l'image justement
perceptible déjà à choisir un projecteur
qui qui est différente tous les autres
par sa résolution mais c'est aussi c'est
une marque différente qui fonctionne
différemment donc c'est un Sony 4K déjà
sur le traitement de l'image c'est
différent mais en plus 4K c'est ce qu'on
appelle 4K c'est la résolution c'est
4000 pixels par ligne alors que la
plupart des autres projecteurs ont 2000
donc deux fois moins en hauteur et en
largeur donc
Age est bien plus 2 minutes de bien
meilleure définition meilleure
luminosité meilleur contraste et je dis
pas ça juste pour faire la promo je l'ai
constaté moi-même je suis très très
content de notre installation c'est un
peu barbare comme terme le 4K pour les
non initiés alors justement on a posé la
question dans les rues de Saint-Quentin
connaissez-vous le 4 cases que c'est un
produit d'appel est-ce que ça va
permettre de séduire les visiteurs
éventuels du grenier à sel voici ce
micro-trottoir connaissez-vous le 4K
non je sais pas ça ne me dit absolument
rien
la gay j'en sais rien moi les réunions
de famille je vois pas 4K
c'est une formule mathématique
ça pourrait être de la décoration ou des
fenêtres ou du mobilier
c'est pas ça
il y a pas des placards qui s'appellent
les cas
bon moi ça me dit rien
des placards du mobilier des fenêtres on
a tout fait dans le micro-trottoir
quatre cas donc on rappelle que c'est la
définition de l'image donc c'est le
rapport le ratio de l'image et c'est de
mettre en ligne et c'est dorénavant ce
procédé qui est utilisé du côté du
grenier à celle à trappe alors on va s'y
rendre justement dans votre cinéma dans
quelques instants on va voir le
reportage nous sommes allés voir comment
cela fonctionne auparavant
expliquez-nous pourquoi avoir décidé à
installer d'installer ce un tel
dispositif aussi perfectionné dans ce
cinéma du grenier à sel parce que je
pense que c'est l'avenir de la
projection cinéma et que tous ceux qui
sont installés en deux cas devront
prochainement passer en 4K donc pour
nous c'est simplement un investissement
c'est qu'on sera pas obligé de faire la
mise à jour plus tard d'ailleurs
dès que le cinéma va ouvrir parce que
vos travaux sont bien galpino vous a
passé la parole mais les travaux ont
pris un peu de retard une année de
retard les travaux ont débuté juin 2011
alors c'est pas juste une couche de
peinture tout le cinéma a été presque on
va dire détruire à l'intérieur et tout
est refait trois salles donc une
nouvelle salle va voir le jour les
travaux devaient se finir novembre 2011
et finalement ce sera plutôt octobre
en novembre 2011 bon on voit où on en
est on est en bas ça fera en retard oui
puisqu'on est censé rouvrir pourquoi ce
retard qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans ce
cinéma c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué on a vécu une année fallait
pas fini difficile
pour les vacances de la Toussaint enfin
c'est l'objectif aujourd'hui qu'on
retrouve pour les vacances de la
Toussaint plein de problèmes des
problèmes d'amiante c'est-à-dire qu'on a
découvert de l'amiante et de l'amiante
qui a été découverte en plus de ce qui
avait déjà été loc donc il a fallu
refaire des travaux de désamiantage on
sait sur les chantiers enfin moi je le
savais pas mais je l'ai découvert que
les autres corps de métiers ne peuvent
pas travailler quand il y a des amisages
parce que ce sont des c'est très
compliqué des films en polyades les gens
qui travaillent avec des masques enfin
etc donc on a eu ça après qu'est-ce
qu'on a eu je crois qu'on a fait une
petite collection quand même de choses
on a découvert de l'eau sous la dalle de
la troisième salle qu'il a fallu casser
parce qu'il en avait pas suffisamment de
hauteur de plafond donc en cassant cette
dalle qui correspond en fait aux
anciennes caves de l'ancien café de
l'eau a été découverte donc il a fallu
supplémentaire parce que déjà il va
falloir faire revenir ensuite cette
spectateurs qui auront pas forcément ce
qui auront perdu l'habitude de venir
voilà on va le dire ce sera difficile au
delà de ça ça coûte plus cher aussi les
travaux bien sûr l'enveloppe travaux
alors je crois qu'il y a eu des
moins-values des plus-values mais ça
c'est quand même une enveloppe qui a
progressé je pense et puis faut pas
oublier de dire que l'agglo heureusement
a pris en compte ces retards de travaux
et à in utiliser la scène pour retard de
travaux la société
et que je dirige et heureusement parce
que sinon je serais pas là pour vous en
parler financière pour l'instant non ça
passe mais il faut pas qu'on ait des
retard de travaux supplémentaires voilà
et aussi pour notre public parce que
comme vous le disiez justement tout à
l'heure un an de retard alors on a bossé
d'expliquer les choses moi je me fais
interpeller à tout bout de champ mais
c'est bien normal je suis là pour
répondre aux questions pourtant il sera
joli futur cinéma
c'est qu'il sera très très beau on sera
aussi équipé en 4K ce sera pas le même
installateur mais c'est la même
technologie et alors pour compléter un
petit peu ce que disait Gaël tout à
l'heure et il a tout à fait raison moi
je souscrit à 100% à ce qu'il dit le 4K
c'est l'avenir c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui effectivement on projette en
deux cas dans les cinémas mais quand on
a été à la journée de la CST alors CST
ça veut dire la commission supérieures
techniques qui en fait valide les
installations des salles de cinéma de
toutes les salles de cinéma en France on
sait déjà qu'on a des fichiers qui
arrivent en 4K le dernier Batman c'est
un fichier 4K tout le monde l'a passé en
4K les seins les salles équipés en deux
cas comme nos grands voisins l'on réduit
l'image pour pouvoir le passer nous
voilà pour le projet du coup plus
comparer justement aux grands voisins on
va dire les multiplex qui donne projette
pas forcément 4 cases ce sont ceux qui
justement vous ont motivé dans cette
voilà ce qu'on appelle cette révolution
ce qu'on a appelé ce soir là la
révolution de ces cinémas de quartier
parce que eux aussi vous ont un peu
boosté il faut rester à la base ou
passer au numérique globalement passer
en numérique
puisque les films à la fin de l'année
2012 n'existeront plus en support
argentique et en France
au départ au grand ni à sel et du coup
Luc a fait le même choix c'est qu'on
choisit vraiment la qualité venez voir
chez nous vraiment vraiment je venais
voir la différence et c'est ces
phénoménal la différence comment ça
fonctionne ce 4 cases un peu barbare si
vous venez de prendre l'émission en
route on parle de deux cas de 4K on
parle de cinéma tout simplement voici ce
reportage réalisé au grenier à celles
qui nous explique comment fonctionne ce
nouveau procédé de diffusion proposé au
greniercel et prochainement du côté du
ciné 7 à Élancourt
des films en HD au grenier à sel c'est
la nouveauté de la rentrée pour le
cinéma de quartier de Trappes
l'installation a nécessité un mois et
demi deux travaux et répond avant tout
un besoin technique et oui dans quelques
temps s'en sera fini de la pellicule au
revoir le projecteur 35 mm de papa place
au tout numérique la résolution des
projecteurs dans les autres salles c'est
une résolution 2 cases c'est-à-dire 2000
points par ligne 2000 pixels par ligne
nous on a choisi un projecteur 4K donc
4000 points par ligne donc la résolution
de l'image est 4 fois meilleures deux
fois plus en hauteur deux fois plus son
largeur deux points c'est un projecteur
du futur en fait c'est l'avenir on a
acheté ce projecteur là de meilleure
qualité pour ne pas avoir à faire les
mises à jour dans quelques années dans
quelques mois le système est géré
entièrement par informatique les films
sont livrés sur disque dur et non plus
sur pellicule une évolution positive
selon les responsables de la salle avec
néanmoins un défaut comme toute données
numériques il peut y avoir des problèmes
on commence aujourd'hui on a Batman ce
soir et déjà le disque dur qu'on nous a
fourni ne marche pas donc il faut
retrouver un autre disque dur pour pour
Batman ce qui est fait notre disque dur
au cinéma de Saint-Cyr-l'École qui ne
l'ont prêté gentiment l'installation de
l'appareil et les travaux de rénovation
coûté près de 100000 €. mais pas
d'inquiétude le prix des billets reste
le même l'un des objectifs étant
d'attirer de nouveaux spectateurs
dernière précision il s'agit bien de
cinéma numérique HD et non pas 2 3D
cette technologie n'est pas encore
disponible au grenier à sel un choix de
la municipalité
pour conclure sur ce plateau sur ces
travaux qui ont été faits dans les
cinémas 3D pourquoi pas de 3D par
exemple au grenier sel c'est un choix
d'abord financier
temporaire pour l'instant c'est on prend
pas tout de suite la 3D on verra plus
tard pour l'instant c'est pas prévu et
du côté du ciné 7 il y aura de la 3D il
y aura la 3D dans la grande salle il
faut savoir que la 3D ça super bien
fonctionné au début et la façon ça
s'essouffle un peu c'est un peu normal
parce qu'il y a force notamment les
Américains de nous vendre des films 2D
gonflés en 3D qui sont pas des vrais
films 3D comme avatar par exemple
les spectateurs
mais on aura la 3D dans les grandes il y
a vraiment un coup qui est difficile à
amortir
en tout cas pour l'instant de grenier à
sel nouveau dispositif de projection qui
sera directement visible vous verrez la
différence vous nous l'avez garanti 4K
donc voilà disponible et puis bientôt du
côté d'ici les 7 à Élancourt qui
rouvrira ses portes on l'espère on le
souhaite pour les vacances de tous du
côté des vacances de la Toussaint merci
donc à tous les deux cette édition du 7
août est presque terminée nous allons à
présent revenir sur les principales
informations à retenir de ce 4 septembre
la rentrée des classes donc ce matin ils
sont plus de 31 000 enseignants du
premier degré comme Caroline Guillard
vous avez aperçu sur ces images de
voisins de Bretonneux qui a donc fait sa
rentrée ce matin côté élève dans le
premier degré ils sont plus de 160000
enfants avoir repris les cours les
effectifs sont en légère hausse le coût
de la rentrée et les fédérations de
parents d'élèves qui s'inquiète plus
2,9% par rapport à 2011 il faut
dorénavant compter jusqu'à 193 euros
pour un élève et qui fait sa rentrée en
classe de 6e en collège et puis le
cinéma Le Grenier c'est la trappe à lui
aussi fait sa rentrée une rentrée
numérique on vient d'en parler avec
transformation de la salle pour une
diffusion en très haute définition high
en cours les travaux du ciné 7 se
poursuivent on l'a vu aussi sur ce
plateau ouverture prévu fin octobre 2012
cette émission sera rediffusée à 19h à
22h31 à minuit réalisation signée et
Xavier jalain on se retrouve demain
mercredi pour un nouveau 7 8 avec
notamment un point complet sur le marché
de l'automobile le Salon de l'automobile
va ouvrir à la fin du mois les
constructeurs sont-ils inquiets élément
de réponse des 18 heures en direct
excellente soirée